this morning president biden is set to
announce new sanctions against russia
in its retaliation for russian
interference in the 2020 election
and the massive solarwinds cyber attack
on u.s companies and government agencies
is also part of a wider refocusing of
priorities including
the withdrawal from afghanistan that the
president officially announced just
yesterday
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this president biden
is taking steps to hit back at russia
over president vladimir putin's attempts
to interfere
in u.s affairs cbs news has learned that
more than 30 russian entities are
expected to be
sanctioned and about 10 russian
intelligence officers will be expelled
from the u.s
since taking office mr biden has not
shied away
from criticizing putin you think he's a
killer
i do the two presidents spoke earlier
this week
and the white house said mr biden made
it clear to the russian leader
that he was prepared to defend america's
interests
including in ukraine where russia has
sent tanks and tens of thousands of
troops to the border
president biden warned putin to
de-escalate the tension
good afternoon the new russia sanctions
come just as president biden has
announced his plan to pull the last
u.s troops out of afghanistan ending the
20-year operation
some of the remaining 2500 troops will
begin to depart next month
and all of them will leave afghanistan
by september 11th
we cannot continue the cycle of
extending or expanding our military
presence in afghanistan
hoping to create ideal conditions for
the withdrawal
and expecting a different result mr
biden went to arlington cemetery
yesterday to honor the more than 2400
troops
who lost their lives in the afghan war
secretary of state anthony blinken is
actually in afghanistan
right now he says that he made the
unannounced visit in order to meet with
u.s
troops and the afghan president to
demonstrate
our commitment to this country but there
are
republicans and some democrats who worry
that a full pullout of u.s
troops is going to embolden the taliban
and destabilize afghanistan anthony
nancy thank you